BUT NOW, IT IS TIME TO PLAY
SUPER FREAKOUT.
(APPLAUSE)
PUBLIC FREAK OUTS USED TO BE
BETWEEN YOU, THE PEOPLE IN
EARSHOT AND WHATEVER YOUR DEITY
OF CHOICE IS, BUT THANKS TO
THE INTERNET WE ARE ALL THE
DEITY OF CHOICE.
I AM GOING TO SHOW YOU A
FREAKOUT THAT WAS POSTED ON THE
YOUTUBES WITH NO EXPLANATION OF
WHY THEY WERE FREAKING
THE [BLEEP] OUT.
AND FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU
TO BUZZ IN AND TELL ME WHY
THEY MAD.
ALL RIGHT. FIRST ONE, A FAMILY
DOLLAR EMPLOYEE BRANDISHING A
BOTTLE OF FEBREZE.
(YELLING OVER EACH OTHER)
(SCREAMING AND CURSING)
>> CHRIS: WHY THEY SO MAD? MAZ.
>> BECAUSE HE WORKS AT A
DOLLAR STORE AND GETS PAID
ON COMMISSION.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. OH YEAH,
THAT'S A BAD DEAL.
>> YEAH.
>> CHRIS: BRAUNGER.
>> THIS IS DEFINITELY A GAME OF
THRONE SPOILER.
SHE SAID, YOU DIDN'T HEAR
THAT KING I DON'T HAVERY GOT
KILLED AND POISONED?
"OH, YOU BITCHI I'M ONLY ON
SEASON TWO."
THAT IS IT.
>> CHRIS: THAT HAD TO BE IT.
YEAH. POINTS.
NEXT ONE, HOW ABOUT THIS
PISSED OFF HOCKEY DAD.
>> GET THE WHEELS ON THE PUCK.
>> WAY TO GO, PAUL.
>> CHRIS: WAY TO GO, PAUL.
>> WAY TO GO, PAUL!
>> CHRIS: OH MY GOD.
>PAUL IS A MONSTER.
MAZ.
>> ONE NIGHT OF DRUNK SEX
AND NOW HE'S GOT TO SPEND
HIS WHOLE LIFE WATCHING
PEEWEE HOCKEY.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, YEAH, THAT'S --
POINTS.
YEP.
SARA.
>> BECAUSE HIS SON WASN'T
EVEN PAYING ATTENTION.
THAT KID JUST FLEW RIGHT BY HIM.
HIS KID SUCKS.
>> CHRIS: YEAH, POINTS.
LAST ONE --
THIS BILINGUAL DAD.
>> OH, DON'T BE [BLEEP] COMING
UP TO ME.
>> SPRECHEN SIE DEUTSCH?
DO YOU SPEAK GERMAN?!
>> CHRIS: I DON'T KNOWS WHAT'S
HAPPENING THERE.
WHY IS THIS GUY DESPERATELY NEED
SOMEONE WHO SPRECHENS SIE
DEUTSCH.
MAZ.
>> HE JUST FOUND OUT THE
NAZI'S LOST.
>> CHRIS: OH, AND HE'S VERY UP
SET BECAUSE HE'S LATE TO GET TO
HIS JOB WHERE HE HAS TO TAKE
FROZEN DOWN ON FOX NEWS.
POINTS. SARA.
>> HE NEEDS TO KNOW IF THE
HOOKER IN HIS CAR IS NINE
OR JUST SAYING "NO."
>> CHRIS: THAT'S [BLEEP]
BRILLIANT.
POINTS.